we'll be like what festival a corn a
full of fries with spicy pilly pilly
sauce consumed at a traditional Italy
Shack it's the stuff Belgian dreams are
made of really good the question is how
can something you know this good being
troubled we need more of this don't we
is a self-confessed free to log an
expert on the traditional Belgian fry
and he's more than a little worried
about its future because it's not an
easy profession and often traditional
stands like this one don't have reliable
licenses for their business something
temporary for example so there's also
uncertainty keeping things going over a
period of time is hard that can be quite
demotivating for young fry cooks that's
not the only issue it may be hard to
believe that many people think Belgian
fries are bad for you here's why
Belgians cooked their fries in beef fat
and not just once or twice it's what
gives them their famous extra crunch so
what's really in Belgian fries is quite
simple actually the main ingredient is
of course potatoes usually the
traditional pinch of variety chosen for
its taste and crunchiness then the
aforementioned beef fat remember double
fried all that adds up to 350 calories
per 100 grams before you've added one of
many yummy sauces which for the record
equates to 13 percent fat consumer
organizations are worried about a
chemical known as acrylamide which is
produced during the double frying
process because this is a long term
effect you are not going to fold that
the day after you eat a product that is
too high with its chemical but this is
an accumulation if you eat those type of
products too often in your lifetime then
you are you increase your risk of cancer
[Music]
there's the tradition and culture
surrounding belgian prize eagle he has a
whole floor at the bed-and-breakfast he
runs stuffed with fry memorabilia his
collection includes paintings and
objects that go back a hundred years
it's the history of the perfect crunch
so even if the future of Belgian fries
seems as murky as old beef fat only is
certain the tradition will survive yes
I'm completely convinced our little
Museum here helps with that it's
important we try to make people
understand the conviviality of the
social tissue and dialogue that's being
created at the fry Shack that's
important for the survival of the
Belgian fries the survival of this
particular Shack is threatened though
the authorities don't want to renew its
licence a familiar tale in the story of
traditional Belgian fries everybody
loves them but not many are ready to
fight for them